most complaints when I hear complaints
when I see tweeted complaints about
trade liberalisation how awful trade is
these are coming on devices that are
manufactured in Japan Singapore Korea
snapped together in China enabled by the
free flow of global capital so Americans
are a bit hypocritical in their
complaints about Ray Daniel I concern is
a trade analyst at the Cato Institute
here in DC and he's got a brand new
paper that analyzes the trans-pacific
partnership and it's got all the answers
and I'm glad to have you here in the
studio hi Daniel hi thanks fat me so
tell us about the trans-pacific
partnership the TPP give us your just
overall assessment what what what do you
think of it without the TPP well it's a
comprehensive trade agreement between
the United States and 11 other countries
together they constitute about forty
percent of global gdp and about a third
of global trade it's really the only
game in town as far as trade
liberalisation goes at the moment the
negotiations began in 2009 it remains to
be seen whether the next president will
be supportive of the TPP both major
party candidates are opposed Gary
Johnson is in favor of it so that that
that's what lies ahead so you've taken
abroad look at the entire green you've
looked at a chapter-by-chapter and sort
of graded each chapter in each part of
it yeah what's your overall assessment
you do like it you just like it as a
mixed bag what's what's your feeling
yeah well it's a mixed bag I think our
conclusion is that it is it's got some
baked in protectionism there's a lot of
liberalisation on par its net
liberalizing it will expand our economic
freedoms and my colleagues and I and my
co-authors and I support it and we think
that Congress should ratify the
agreement well let's talk about maybe
some of the concerns first and some of
the reasons some people think it might
not be worth rescuing like the
intellectual property provisions there's
been some concern that it tilts tour it
does tilt towards large corporations for
example the pharmaceutical industry or
is that true are those legitimate
concerns there is reason to debate
intellectual property and whether it
should be protected I happen to think it
should be protected
my colleagues due to the question is how
much we graded the the intellectual
property chapter we give it a grade of a
four so it's kind of protectionist
because we we think there is too much
protection particularly in the copyright
area in under US law its life of the
author plus 50 years in our trade
agreements its life of the author Plus
70 years so intellectual property
protection is by definition
protectionism in the patent area with
respect to pharmaceuticals there's not
much in the TPP that pushes beyond what
is currently legal in the United States
so no no US laws will need to change to
accommodate the the patent provisions of
the TPP but I think the talk about
overreaching IP protections was is more
extravagant than it then the reality it
we really took a closer look at it and
we don't see anything in there that is
good it's going to tie anybody's hands
Internet service providers also are not
really on the hook to do anything that
they're not doing right now we gave it a
protection is great because it does go a
little too far but it's not as bad as
some of the rhetoric would have us
believe and so in what way do the good
outweigh the bad in your view most
tariffs around the world around among
these 12 countries are going to go to 0
over the course of 10 years so there's
going to be huge markets for us
agricultural exports are going to be us
consumers are going to have access to
products from Japan and Vietnam and and
the other TPP countries that they did
not have before and you know that's
really the essence of these trade
agreements to get rid of those border
barriers we one of the reasons that the
trade agreements have expanded to
include what I call sort of global
governance is the nature of trade has
changed it used to be the case that
products were produced all in one
country and then export it to another
country and the only thing that really
concerned exporters and importers we're
border bears tariffs customs procedures
corruption nowadays because of the
increase in cross-border investment
transnational supply chains
international company
are competing in domestic space and
protectionism lurks in domestic
regulations in procurement decisions and
in various rules that are murky so trade
agreements now are trying to go after
these rules to harmonize them or two to
make them more transparent and I think
you run the risk of coming up with a
global solution when local solutions
might be be better however it's look
it's legitimate it's a legitimate ground
for considering the expansion of trade
agreements but yet we have to traipse
carefully can you address the the
seeming tie that has turned against
trade certainly in this presidential
candidacy way we have both the left and
the right you have both Trump and you
have Sanders really coming out very
strongly against trade and influencing
Hillary as well who used to call the TPP
the gold standard and now she seems to
be moving against it it seems like
address some of those concerns does does
an agreement like TPP make it easier for
large corporations to ship manufacturing
jobs out of the country I don't think it
makes it easier for them to do that they
can they can do that right now in fact
investment is very fluid going in and
out of the United States one thing
that's overlooked in the in the
discussion is there is more foreign
investment in u.s. manufacturing than in
any other countries manufacturing sector
by a huge amount there's about 1.1
trillion dollars of foreign investment
in u.s. companies meaning you know Honda
here in the United States Michelin here
in the United States the second-largest
destination is China with about 500
billion so despite all this talk of
manufacturing decline and atrophy
foreigners have certainly not lost faith
or interest in producing the United
States the rhetoric that we have heard
about trade and manufacturing in the US
this presidential election is not really
that different from previous
presidential elections ever since the
NAFTA debate in 1992 you paying twelve
thirteen dollars fourteen dollars now at
the factory workers and you can move
your factory south the border pay about
an hour for your labor have no health
care that's most expensive single
element making a car have no
environmental controls no pollution
controls and no retirement and you don't
care about anything but making money
they will
a job sucking sound going south so trade
has been topical particularly during the
primaries Republicans appeal to the
right with sort of nationalistic
messages it's Team USA against Team
China and exports are our points imports
are their points in the trade account is
the scoreboard and we have a deficit
which means we're losing a trade and
we're losing because the foreign team is
cheating that that's Trump's message
Bernie Sanders's messages trade only
benefits rich corporations and wealthy
people when in fact exact opposite is
true it's the big corporations can
endure the costs of tariffs the costs of
impediments regulatory impediments
smaller companies that are challengers
to the domestic incumbents and need to
export to achieve economies of scale
they they have a harder time absorbing
the costs of protectionism so same with
consumers wealthier Americans don't
consume a lot of foreign products
believe it or not Americans richer
Americans consume a lot of services it's
poor Americans who consume more products
and most of most of those products do
come from abroad we have very low
tariffs overall about 2% but we have
tariff Peaks on life's necessities like
clothing and footwear so if I'm Bernie
Sanders and I and I'm a progressive I
should be advocating for elimination of
those tariffs but I haven't I for some
reason I'm being more responsive to the
special interests the labor unions the
environmentalists who oppose trade for
other reasons but anyway it's been this
year it's persisted the ante trade
rhetoric and the campaign trail has
persisted beyond the conventions into
the general election I happen to think
that Hillary Clinton will pivot again if
she becomes the president I think
certainly she will support the TPP as
she did before she will recognize its
importance as an economic injury or
strategic tool and so she just needs to
be more assertive about the benefits of
trade she took an anti trade stance in
that in 2008 along with Obama and they
were going to open up reopen NAFTA and
they both abandoned that money be
president she'll abandon this this
rhetoric as well so it is a puzzle to me
the why trade has become an issue and
not just among certain you know pressure
groups but it's quite popular to be
against trade among people but if what
you say is true and I think that it is
that every time we go shopping we go to
Walmart or anywhere and we see the
benefits and get the benefits of trade
yeah why is it why is it unpopular why
has it well I have people turned against
it if they're feeling the benefits of it
every single day trade is become a
catch-all for inequality income
inequality wealth inequality inequality
of opportunity trade liberalisation has
sort of been embraced by the inside the
beltway elites and it's it's the best
deal and Americans want to storm the
Bastille they want to storm the ivory
tower where we have you know trade
analysts pointing at the benefits of
trade liberalization most complaints
when I hear complaints when I see
tweeted complaints about trade
liberalization and how awful trade is
these are coming on devices that are
manufactured in Japan Singapore Korea
snapped together in China enabled by the
free flow of global capital so Americans
are a bit hypocritical in their
complaints about trade Daniel I concen
is a trade analyst at the Cato Institute
he's got a brand new paper that analyzes
the trans-pacific partnership in detail
and it's really worth checking out
Daniel thanks for joining us my pleasure
thanks I'm Todd crane and for reason TV